should we go for the the big conspiracy
yeah Oh what is that
China China realizing that Trump is
going to dismantle their efforts to you
know seize our production and things
like that yeah has gone all out and are
exploiting racial tensions as a key
weakness yeah in a multicultural
democratic system this this is what one
thing about this there's a video of me
going viral it's still going viral its
liberal still being passed around
liberal you know says he's gonna vote
for Trump in that video I talked about
how Democrats are in bed with China and
and you you were like yeah they've made
their bet they were they were didn't
that's trouble was not supposed to win
Hillary is supposed to win they probably
lost all this money so that that
conversation you and I had was in that
video and at the end of the video I'm
like I'm gonna Trump like I'm saying I
don't mind but it got deleted say so
fast and several times it is being
pushed down they don't want people to
think that at all
it was probably the China bit not the
Trump bit that that's what I'm alluding
to right yeah yeah yeah it has nothing
to do with Trump it has everything to do
with the fact that China doesn't want
anyone thinking about us do you see
what's going on with the tick-tock stuff
yeah dude okay so for those who don't
know tick-tock steals your information
that's simply put simply put they steal
your information they find it it's more
than just what's on your clipboard that
was BS it you you accept tick-tock they
have access oh yeah and that's that's a
Chinese a company and we're trying to
ban it Amazon just banned all their
company or all of their employees that
have access to the Amazon server why
wait apparently a story came out saying
that was a mistake
Oh what that he didn't say that they
weren't supposed to ban it they weren't
supposed to do it I wonder it I wonder
if they did and then something happened
and they were like we're sorry China
yeah because I said we're gonna ban
Amazon
yeah because China you know makes who
knows how many of the products the
Amazon slings everybody did you see the
Josh Holly thing well no it was when he
asked the NBA to make like a free set if
you're gonna do you know political
jerseys why don't you do a back the blue
you know support the troops
free Hong Kong yeah when the guy
responded with fu Wow alright yeah it
was at for you right so now and then he
tweeted out he was like don't criticize
China yeah now we're seeing these tick
tock things popping up where everyone's
like we love China China is amazing we
yes praise praise China nice joke yet
well I I don't know
to be honest I'm not sure no I have no
idea this world is crazy right now
living in there's a journalist two
covers this kind of youth internet
culture stuff her name is Taylor Lorenz
okay and she's been subjected to a big
conscious for the record everybody Lydia
just did some air quotes oh that's
because she well Tim's gonna talk about
it because she covers the topic that I
think is not very valuable but all whoa
well listen you said he said journalist
and you were like it's because just
saying I had AI I happen to like Taylor
Lorenz I think she's all right okay and
I know a lot of people are mad at her
and I think her beat is reality it's
it's and I mean this with all respect
it's like a reality TV MT it's like dude
we used to put 16 year old kids on MTV
and and film them ever doing every bit
you know Ryan Sheckler had his show and
he was a kid so I think there's certain
things to criticize her over for sure so
I don't even know that go ahead
journalist for the New York Times and
we're one of the things that sparked a
controversy was that she was
communicating with Kellyanne Conway's
daughter okay and it was like a family
drama and a lot of people are like kid
you know political actors children are
off-limits and her argument was
Kellyanne Conway's daughter was already
putting this stuff out right I'm not a
fan of that you know III agree like
there's probably a line you shouldn't be
messing the kids but when as it pertains
to tick-tock she's been covering this
and so the next like bit of controversy
is her perspective on this story about
tick-tock is these kids are all really
like freaking out they're gonna lose
their careers their followings and what
does that mean for them it's it's their
connection to dopamine actually exactly
that's what I tweeted Oh China got our
children addicted to digital crack and
we got now we gotta cut them off that's
nailed it dude factory what I would have
said but Twitter is the same thing
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook is
just and and and the u.s. is like yo
well were the dealers man we're not
gonna let you you know interfere on what
we got going because we control
everything whatsapp whatsapp is huge
around the world America well everybody
wants everybody wants to be cherished
everybody wants to feel valuable they
wanna they it's in our nature to were
humans we come together you know as a
community that's how we've gotten this
far that's how we've taken over the
planet so now you know we're
deconstructing the the family home so
where's where are people getting that
connection it's you know at you're
taught like oh it's it's so bad to live
at your parents home
you don't live on your own anymore and
it's like yeah there's nothing wrong
with that I don't care i mean i i live
on my own I've lived on my own since I
was 17 and and you know it's like I
don't see anything wrong with it because
it's community now they're finding it
online now yo now now online when you
take that away from them that now I mean
that is their community that's that
that's where they get that feeling you
know that they're not getting in real
life I'm gonna be and we got to bring
that back and it's that is very
important I may be I'm gonna be very
careful on how I describe this but let
me just tell you how easy it is for some
of these companies to trick kids into
getting on their platform you create a
social media app you buy you buy a
handful of Facebook ads and Instagram
ads promoting the app showing young
people dancing and having a good time
when a young person signs up you then
give them fake followers slowly over
time so they the dopamine trigger Wow
when I do a post I get a bunch of likes
this works once they do they start
bragging about how many followers they
have and their friends want to get
involved so you plant the seeds using
bots to trick them but so here's what
happens with Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook lets you know insta vac cheat
awk about getting rid of Instagram likes
and go because it's giving people a
dopamine you know rush you post a photo
10,000 likes and you're like yes the
next day you want 11,000 more points
more points so they're like maybe we'll
get rid of it Twitter talked about
getting rid of follower count retweet
count light count Instagram has the
reason they haven't is because that's
the own
only reason they exist yeah Twitter
Instagram Facebook they would not exist
if there was no metrics on them that's
true because you'd post I agree and the
only thing you'd see our replies mm-hm
and you might get some replies it might
be fine so you might be willing to
engage but people people are all about
the follower count the subscription
account that how many views that I get
this time so what happens is some apps
and being vague on purpose to avoid
lawsuits artificially exploit this it's
just that simple you get a 17 year old
kid and he thinks he's talking to his
fans and it's it's one guy in China
pressing buttons going like you know
there he goes now he believes you know
there's 50 more likes he thinks he's
where it's working just got a finisher
they're addicted and when you gotta take
it away they go but I have so many
followers here's the funny thing about
the Taylor Lorenz story is why I brought
it up some people were saying I have got
all of my followers on tik-tok it
doesn't translate you know I've got ex
followers on tik-tok but barely any
actually follow me on Twitter Instagram
it's because they're not so so the
reason I brought this up we were talking
about the the deep web China
conspiracy right so now I'm seeing these
weird tick top videos of like how
awesome China is and who has who has
tick topic accounts kids young kids
who's the most susceptible to being
converted to whatever ideology you you
shove down their throat when they have
your attention when they're getting
their dopamine from from them instead of
their parents you know it used to be
like your parents would be like we're
proud of you and it'd be like wow I mean
someone I that's all I need I don't need
the Internet I don't need TV I don't
need anything to know that I am
important period done because my parents
showed me that and it's like that's gone
that's and that is so essential now now
they're getting it from China so from
fake BOTS I mean sure it's a it's a
conspiracy you know but this is
everything I just said still remains
true this is what I think the Trump side
is missing a strong propaganda wing you
technically have it
the memes myths and the jokes yeah but
these are aboveboard on the level
engagements and but those are people
that are not being paid they're doing it
because they love it right so when it
comes to say carpe donk Tim who is the
master meme Smith of choice grow the
president and he puts these I I love
that the lights went out at the debate
remember that one no and then all of a
sudden smoke fills the room and then
Trump walks out of the smoke and it's
playing crazy train or something it's
just so good but it is meant to be fun
funny and a joke right doesn't tell you
anything about the president's positions
it's meant it's meant to make you have a
good time mm-hmm that helps Trump but
what the left has is first of all all
these big tech companies will ban
conservative opinions like reddit right
now is is the most insane echo chamber
of establishment leftism yeah but if
Trump tried to buy an ad band they you
know Facebook has you know flat or
Twitter as flagged Trump so if Trump
even wanted to create you know a
propaganda wing they wouldn't let him do
it yes the establishment is completely
opposed to him and so what Trump has is
for one he has his base it's not
particularly
iiiiii it's relatively large I think
they say it's like 35% of the country
then he has the center-right Trump is
better than the alternative
so the Trump base these are the people
who will vote for Trump no matter what
he does then you have the more moderate
conservatives who are like I wish Trump
could be better but he's certainly
better than you know Biden yeah and then
you have a bit of the moderates who are
like I guess I have to vote Trump and
the Republicans because of what's
happening what what he doesn't get is he
can't grow the zealous fanaticism
because the Machine is against him okay
so and they're using that that
propagandistic machine to create the
anti-trump vote which is really
interesting now Joe Biden doesn't do
anything you know why does nobody is
voting for yeah people are voting
against Trump exactly not for Biden so
Facebook announced they're gonna ban
they may ban political ads which I mean
that is a move against Trump period you
know what yeah prop wall project Veritas
did that hold expose about how they ban
and
a trump supporter period no matter what
they're like oh yeah I see a trump
supporter a band well so think about
this way if Joe if people are voting for
or against Trump okay
and they banned political ads I think
that would only hurts Trump no I think
the opposite because Trump ads are
already being pushed down and you know
getting gotten rid of like we saw the
the project Verito but at least they
reach some people
okay well then all the the Biden ads
wouldn't reach anyone there are none oh
there's not I mean there are Biden ads
but no one is voting for Biden right
okay so if Trump needs to counter the
propaganda with his message and they say
we're banning all ads and then the media
continues to spam anti Trump propaganda
people are gonna vote for or against
Trump that's it that's what the polls
say nobody that's why they don't care
about Biden he is he is a nothing
candidate because it's either for or
against Trump yeah that's true so if
Trump can't post ads they don't need
Biden to post ads they just need the
media to do its thing and there you go
everything will be Trump bad yeah that's
the move that's and that's I think
Twitter banned political ads right is it
they did I believe so there you go just
to hurt Trump because nobody cares about
Joe Biden but okay they care about and
don't like Hillary so when they make
that switch that's gonna be when they do
okay so listen I think it's I think it's
hilarious it's come to this point but if
the Republicans don't take everything
and that's a big ask I know and two
three or four hasn't happen welcome to
the resistance you will be as far as
anyone's concerned in the gross minority
in terms of culture your ideas will be
oppressed shut down and you'll be told
to sit down and shut up because the
machine is against you this is your last
hope if the Democrats get in even one
one branch House Senate or presidency
230 or form can't happen that's true and
it's like I said it's not just 230
reform they've got to go one step beyond
and actually like file suits and defend
it and challenge it and that will only
work not only that I mean let's be real
the Supreme Court just gave half the
jurisdiction of Oklahoma back to the
Native Americans which I'm sure you know
a lot of people are happy with but is
very detrimental precedent to the rest
of the United States a lot of people are
hitting me up about that and I'm I
haven't looked fully into it but from
what I'm hearing from many different
people it's it's all about just the
specifics of land ownership doesn't
change right it's just the specifics of
Native Americans that live in that area
and that have been arrested right for
crimes so it's a narrow ruling right
meaning they've asserted several
positions and then said this is about
federal crimes committed on this land
right the state will not have
jurisdiction over Native Americans but
within their opinion they said this is a
reservation which means precedent has
been set to open the door for a wave of
more lawsuits so that that's why I say
you're gonna get two narratives on this
one mm-hmm
there's a lot of people who are like no
no don't worry about it but the problem
with that is I don't trust it because
there are quite literally people in
Seattle for instance in the government
saying they want to tear down the system
Ilyn omar saying tear down the system is
crazy so when the Supreme Court does
this I say I'm not gonna err on the side
of it's no big deal I'm gonna err on the
side of woe yeah we should have you know
Oklahoma needs to have jurisdiction over
their statement I agree thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you